TED SANDER: Thanks, everybody.
My name is Ted.
I'm here to talk about
components, specifically
Angular Dart components.
I am an infrastructure
tech lead that specifically
works on widgets for
many of the applications
that we have at Google.
And last year, I
was up here, and I
was talking at the Dart
Summit about the way
that Google teams use Dart in
Angular to build their web apps
and how they are very
productive in doing so.
And it's been quite
a great year for us.
Maybe you haven't seen it, but
we've had tons of launches.
We have a lot of
products out there.
We have many, many users
coming to our applications
in production.
And we're getting
some reviews back,
and we're really liking
these reviews-- stuff
like its sleek, comfortable,
feel and approachable
sophistication apparent
throughout this new design.
The new, responsive
user interface
that makes it easy and
more efficient to use.
Nice material design
animations all
throughout the website,
which obviously
help making the overall look
and feel infinitely better.
Now, I don't know about
infinitely better.
But if a user says that
about your application,
you're doing the right things.
This one is my favorite.
We haven't run into any
delays in the new AdWords
UI and zero loading screens.
Even more, some tasks now seem
almost instantly completed.
Now, they're not quite
instantly completed,
but it is something
that we strive for.
And these reviews
came from three
very separate
applications that we've
launched in the last year.
But you can see common patterns.
They're loving the new UI.
They're loving the speed.
They're loving the
material design.
And all of these three teams
are throughout the whole world.
Two of them are
from Europe itself.
We're going to have
one Dan is going
to talk about a
little bit later,
and David is going to talk about
how they've used Dart to make
their applications great.
But something that's
common between these
is they're actually all
using the same widgets.
And it allows our applications
to get a lot of velocity
so they can all get these
wonderful reviews that they can
get feedback from their
users that they're just
delighted to use it.
And it's something
that we really
strive for in our applications.
But we've heard from our
external developments
that UI development can
still feel like this for you.
It's a little slow.
You don't really want to have
to write that common button.
You don't have to want to write
that common tab component.
You just want to have to work
on the application logic that's
special to your app that will
make your users delighted,
and you don't
really have to worry
about all this other stuff.
And Dart does a pretty good
job with the core libraries
that let you get up and
running really, really quickly.
But we want the development
to feel like this,
like you're in a rocket ship.
And this is the way that
development inside of Google
feels like.
You can really concentrate on
your application and your logic
to delight your
users and make sure
that you're doing
really great stuff
rather than worrying about
some of this more simple stuff.
But we've heard from
you that there's
a piece missing, that
there's something that's
keeping you guys from making
these wonderful applications
yourself and making it hard
to get those wonderful reviews
that we saw.
So today, we announced
Angular Dart Components,
production-quality
widgets for everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, today, we're just
giving you a preview
of what you'll come to see.
We've got some kinks to work
out still for a general release.
But we really want to get you
excited about using the widgets
and allow you to get some of
these wonderful reviews, some
of these wonderful
applications for you yourself.
Now, this is not just
a solitary effort.
There's not just a team of five
people at Google doing this.
There's actually
hundreds of Googlers
that have contributed
to these widgets.
Many of them are
in this room today,
but there's many, many more
across the entire world
contributing code
and making sure
that they're production-quality
and they work well
for their users and
for their applications.
And we get many more
bug requests from them,
too, to validate that
they're working correctly.
And we're very excited to
bring you into our community,
to have you use these
components and help us
and to make them
better so that you
can get the wonderful
usefulness out of them.
So today, I really wanted to
talk about three key principles
that our infrastructure
team works on
and everything that we work
with, widgets specifically.
And that's velocity,
usability, and efficiency.
And [? Ferhat ?] [? and Maton ?]
already talked to you a little
bit about this on how we
do it with Angular itself,
but I'm going to talk to
you about how we do it
in our widgets.
First, velocity-- letting you
concentrate on your product.
You don't have to worry
about the widget itself.
We provide a set of material
design core widgets written
in Angular Dart for you
so that you can quickly
work on the application logic
that is important to you.
There's over 100 widgets that
we have internally at Google,
and we're going to
show you some today.
It was actually just published
before I came up here,
and you can take a look.
And many of the ones that
you see on the screen,
they're going to be available.
This isn't ready
to be released yet,
but eventually, we're going
to give you a gallery.
Internally to Google,
we have a gallery
that actually allows our
developers to quickly see
what widgets are available.
It gives them documentation
about how to use the widget,
and also gives them
examples so they
can see how the developer
meant the widget to be used.
It allows us to
quickly and easily see
what's possible with the widget
and also how we could quickly
get those widgets
into our production
and into our application.
Something else that
we use a lot within--
and this isn't quite ready for
release yet, but we'll see it
soon-- is that we use SaaS
a lot in our components.
It isn't just that the
components have SaaS.
We actually provide
mixins and variables
so that you can have the
material to design language
within your component so that
you can have your CSS be very
semantic, and you
can semantically
say what you were meaning to do.
This is valuable for what
we have within Google,
because no longer do we
have just variables mixed
in throughout our CSS.
Instead, it's very easy
to make our CSS readable,
and we can figure out exactly
what the designer meant
for the component and also
what the developer meant
when they were implementing it.
So instead of having all
these random variables
for material shadow,
now we can just
say we want this component
to have material shadow,
and it automatically
gets it, and it's clear
that that's what the
developer was trying to do.
You're not copying and pasting
these values from somewhere.
Now, [? Maton ?]
already explained
how Angular is bringing
you page objects
if you want to use them to
make your testing easier.
We're also going to provide
page objects for the component
itself.
And this makes it that much
easier for you to write tests
when you use the component.
You actually get the logic
and its very simple interface
to start testing the
component instead
of having to write all
this code on a component
that you didn't even write
yourself just to test it.
So in this example, we see that
we have the material input page
object, and we can just
have simple methods
to interact with it, like
being able to type values
into the input and to
be able to see what
the value of that input is.
Usability-- we
want the components
to be usable for
both our developers,
but also for our users.
Accessibility is for everybody.
It's not just for a
certain set of users.
If your UIs are accessible,
they make them easier
to use for everybody-- me,
you, my dad, everybody.
And we actually gave a
preview of this to our GDEs,
and we asked them what they
thought about these components.
And you can just
take my word for it
that we think that our
APIs are pretty nice,
but I wanted to give you some
quotes for them about what they
thought.
Monty, who couldn't be with us
today, he said that coding them
has a great feel.
They have syntactic brevity.
They seem lighter and
better-integrated into my app.
Faisal, who is here
today and is going
to give a presentation
later, he said yes, yes, yes.
I love this.
Super easy to configure.
This is the kind of reactions
that we want from all of you.
So how did we do this?
How does it look like?
Well, one thing is
we want these widgets
to look like idiomatic HTML.
If you notice, there's these
three values right here
are actually doing
all the same thing.
But the first one looks
like a very-- just
like a standard HTML
element that you
might find in your browser.
You can just quickly say
that this button is disabled,
and it will be disabled.
The second one works, too, if
you want to pass it the string.
And the third one is if you
actually need a binding for it.
So this allows it to be dynamic.
This actually does save a
little bit of performance
also, because in the first
two, you know that it's static.
You know that it's
never going to change,
so it's a little bit faster.
And then the third one will
give you that dynamic nature
that you're looking for.
Sorry about that.
We also work very, very closely
with the Angular Dart team.
I'm in their office pretty
much once a week-- they
can attest to this--
bugging them all the time.
And we want to make sure that
the components are idiomatic
Angular Dart, that it's the
Angular that you would expect
to write in your
own applications
that the Angular team
would like to see
written for your applications.
Notice that his outputs,
like you would expect
with the events that you come
to love or hate from Angular,
and that it uses the standard
forms library, like NG Model,
so that it just works well
with the rest of Angular.
Another thing that
we want to provide
is we want to make it really
easy to use our models.
So in each of these
widgets, they're
all backed by the same model,
the selection model class.
And while it would
make it easy to switch
the widgets if you needed to,
that doesn't happen very often.
The real benefit of this is
that you can learn an API once.
You can learn the
selection model API once,
and then you can use it over
and over again, very quickly,
in tons of different
widgets so that you're not
learning a different model
for every single widget
you want to use.
And it has
accessibility built in.
We really wanted to make
it easy for you guys
to have accessible applications
that work well for your users.
In this example--
you'll see this
throughout all of our widgets--
we have this trigger pattern
instead of just
listening for click.
We want the user to be able to
interact with it with a mouse
or with the keyboard, whatever
way they see fit, whatever
works better for them.
So we have this trigger
pattern that we see.
Also, things such as buttons
and tabs and inputs--
when you have it disabled,
it will automatically
set the [? RE ?]
properties for you
so that it makes
sense in the browser
too if you're still
getting accessibility.
So when you say
something is disabled,
then it's going to work
right for accessibility also.
Now, while we can't cover
all of your use cases,
we hope that we make it
that much easier to make
your application accessible.
Efficiency, the last
topic-- performance
is the feature in
our applications.
Performance is very
important to us.
I think you've
heard a lot about it
today, about how we're trying
to make everything very, very
performant and keep
everything fast.
Our users love it when
our applications are fast.
It's the thing that
they want the most.
It's the thing that they
care about the most.
And our widgets need to
be able to support that.
One way that we do this is we
actually have latency tests,
like [? Ferhat ?]
was telling you
earlier today, that
are run on our widgets
every single code change.
And it allows us to
build graphs like this.
This is a real graph that
came from one of our widgets.
And if you notice
the top line, that
is the cold start performance.
That's the performance
the very first time
that it's initialized
on the page.
Down here, that is
the warm performance.
That's what happens
for every other time
that it's initialized.
It's a lot faster.
This is because that's going
through a JS cold loop.
It's a good amount slower,
and it's pretty fast
when you've actually
rendered it once.
But we want to make
sure both numbers are
very good and very performant.
So you can notice there's
a pretty big hump here
in this benchmark.
So what happened?
Well, my coworker
Zach, he actually
came through, sent in a CL.
He was changing some of
the, I think, accessibility
on something.
And all of a sudden, I
got an email that night
that said that there was
a performance regression.
So I emailed Zack, and I said,
hey, did you expect this?
Was this what you
were expecting?
Did you expect it to take
about seven milliseconds longer
for this simple action?
He said no, I didn't
really think it was
going to be any performance.
I thought it was going
be performance neutral.
I'll go investigate it.
So he took a look,
and it turns out
that the API call that
he was calling was more
expensive than he imagined.
And he switched it
with a different one.
And you can notice that the
latency graph came back down.
And he actually made
it a little bit faster
than it was before he started.
So we can quickly see
when things go wrong
when things are
hurting our performance
or making it better.
Also, when Chrome drops,
our graphs change, too.
So we've had
instances where we've
had performance
regressions on our widgets,
and we've actually went to the
Chrome team, and we said, hey,
did you expect this?
Was this regression
something that you
wanted within your browser?
And they said, oh, let
me take a look at it.
And they came back, and two
versions later in Chrome,
we actually had it fixed.
So we can actually catch
other problems, too.
Another problem that
we're trying to solve
is layout thrashing.
So naively in your
application, it's
pretty easy to read a value
from the DOM, change that value,
and then reread it.
And you might think
that this is OK.
But in fact, what
you're doing is
you're causing the browser
to reflow and to re-render
the page.
This can be pretty expensive.
It can be 15 milliseconds
or longer just
between these two method calls.
And that's something we want to
try to avoid as much as we can.
So within your own
application-- or
within your own
simple widget, it
might be easy to move all the
reads before all the writes,
and make sure that it
happens in the right way,
and that you don't
trigger reflow.
But that's really
hard to do when
you're talking about the
very large applications
that we build at Google.
You can't control
all the source code
to make sure that the DOM is
coordinated in the right way.
So we actually have a service.
It's the DOM service.
And this is in the preview.
It allows you to say that
you want to schedule a read
or schedule a write and make
sure that the reads happen
for the mutate so that we don't
get that-- we don't trigger
that reflow, that
we're not paying
the price for the layout.
We use this in all our widgets.
And you can use them
in your applications,
too, to make sure that your
render speed is really, really
performant.
Lastly for performance, I want
to talk about change detection
optimization.
So [? Ferhat ?]
already talked to you
about how change
detection can make
your application pretty slow.
If you have a naive
application, it's
pretty easy to just
use change detection,
and everything will
work fast enough,
and you won't really
notice any slowdown.
But when we're talking about
the size of the application
that we build at
Google, change detection
starts becoming a
problem really quickly.
And our components
actually help you with this
as much as you can.
We enable you to
do better things
for your change detection.
And we do that in two ways.
One way is that if we
have anything that's
off the screen-- anything
that the user isn't actually
seeing right now, but we
need it in our application--
think of a tab.
If you have five
tabs on your screen,
you're only showing
the content of one,
and the other four
aren't being shown.
But naively today, if you
just build tabs really simply,
all of those tabs are going
to be in your change detection
tree.
They're all going to be
part of your application.
What we do is we
allow you to mark
that the tabs-- that
this part of the code
may not be on the screen
to the user right now.
It allows us to remove it
from the change detection tree
and keep your application
just a little bit faster.
The other thing that we provide
is that the widgets themselves
enable on push, and they
will soon enable set state.
This allows you to keep
your application fast.
Because if you want to use
these cool new features,
everything in your
sub-tree, if you
want to make a component
on push or use set state,
everything needs to
support that capability.
So the components
won't keep you behind.
They do support on push
today, and they'll soon
support set state.
So it allows you to really
build these fast applications
if you wish.
If you just want to use the
standard change detection,
that works, too.
Everything will just work fine.
So again, I want to thank you
from all the people at Google.
This is really a
labor of love for us.
There is, like I said, hundreds
engineers worked into this.
We all love these components.
I have people that work on these
components that really don't
even want to do their day
job, because they really
love working on the
components itself.
So I hope that you guys will
get a lot of use out of it.
Next year, I want
to see great reviews
that we saw for
our applications,
I want to start seeing
them for your applications.
So go out and start
building some great apps
so that we can have some
wonderful stories to tell
next year.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]